violence among teens it is a hot topic
across the valley with several fights
happening in our schools what about teen
dating violence well madison kimbrough
spoke with some local experts about what
they're seeing right now and some things
parents should really watch out for yeah
we've been covering several school
violence incidents for several weeks now
and in a recent facebook live posted by
safe nest teen dating violence is
another big component to be addressed
physical fighting in our schools is a
growing concern and in a recent facebook
live post by the domestic abuse
treatment center safe nest the
discussion of teen dating violence was
at the forefront people are behaving
badly and
we too often a society want to say oh
you're behaving badly let me lay you
down with punishments what we need to
ask is why what are the mental health
supports that we need to put on this and
whether it be a fight between friends
over an individual or a teen couple
social media escalates it school is
eight hours a day and i can decide to
physically avoid someone if i choose i
cannot sit at that table in the
cafeteria i can take a different route
to math social media is 24 hours a day
as for educating our youth liz
ortenberger with safeness says they've
been trying to implement a plan of
action for years within the district but
it continues to be a struggle we have
been trying to get into the school
district to lead more programs it's very
very difficult to get into ccsd and do
this type of education we hear those
same stories with our domestic violence
kids where they didn't realize that
getting hit by a partner was wrong
courtney burns a counselor at faith
lutheran middle and high school says
there's some key signs to look out for
when dealing with teen dating violence
the minute we start to see some
controlling behaviors whether that looks
like
you know i need to go through your phone
or i don't want you talking to that
person to me that is always a really red
flag that there's a potential for things
to escalate physically as well
now the best advice for parents get to
know your child's friends and their
parents and be a part of their community
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now